turkish forces say this was a prison for
islamic state fighters
troops busted in expecting to take
charge
only to find the jail in tel aviat empty
turkey blamed a kurdish militia claiming
the inmates had been abducted
but a kurdish source denied there was an
is prison in the area
ankara's offensive against the kurds is
still raging
making it hard to establish the facts
but there's alarm
about what will happen to thousands of
is prisoners as the tanks roll in
president trump even claimed kurdish
forces might be freeing them
deliberately
before saying turkey and europe could
easily recapture them
but those involved in the years-long
fight against islamic state might beg to
differ
across the border in that direction is
the syrian town of kabbani
and beyond that the city of manbij both
were threatened or controlled by islamic
state
until u.s led coalition forces allied
with the kurds battled hard
to gain control of them now these same
u.s
and british special forces are preparing
to withdraw from syria
as turkish-backed troops turn their
attention to manbij
the kurds abandoned and desperate have
struck a deal with archefo president
assad
it means regime forces are returning to
parts of northeastern syria
opening a new front stuck in the middle
as always are civilians
where are the united nations let them
come to see the blood of our children on
the floor
why don't they show up our children are
gone our girls are gone and our strength
is gone
world leaders have urged turkey's
president to stop
but to no avail
regardless of the threats and pressures
we are determined to continue the
operation until the end
i am stating clearly we will absolutely
finish the job we started
[Music]
could be the beginning of the end game
for syria's grinding war
the final outcome as yet unknown debra
haynes sky news to rich
on the turkey syria border